at the same time this might also be a
reference or certainly seems to be
connected to the common idea in Gnostic
cosmology that the Divine eons in the
ploma are usually conceived of as
existing in male female pairs but just
like in many other so-called Gnostic
text if we can call this one that
there's an emphasis on the ugliness of
this world the prison from which we must
escape unlike the other Christians who
interpret scripture literally and
misunderstand Christ's message and the
nature of the world the true Community
knows the esoteric truths and aim to
escape the world and body instead
clothing themselves with a body of light
and live out a spiritual existence like
we said this is achieved through the
teachings of Jesus particularly the true
esoteric teachings confer to select
people and involve some kind of Union of
dualities and ultimately a union with
the Divine itself